you know there's a difference between a
kid who can play basketball and a hooper
you know the uber is someone who can go
get a bucket at any given time
for his team if someone just plays
basketball just knows the fundamentals
and
just plays basketball the right way i
guess there's nothing wrong with that
but
i'm a hooper for sure for sure
i wonder how it is that um because
you've had one of the
more unique stories out of everybody on
the team was just like
this kind of like reintroduction to the
world right everybody saw you in the
national state
high school with okay what you did and
now it's not you know now you're
reintroducing yourself to the world
what was that like uh getting
comfortable also with just like telling
your story
about what you've been through over the
last couple years
uh i mean even though i was i've been
through a lot
a lot of ups and downs like you said a
lot of people knew who i was before
and that's like reintroducing myself but
it was it was really easy for me to open
up to the camera crew
and tell my story because they made it
easy for us they were they were good
people they were cool
um they were open they told some of
their stories um
and ultimately they i got comfortable
with telling my story because they were
real they were they were good people
and it just made it that much easier the
other things that
you took from that experience that you
were like hey at the end of the day i
needed that
um and like what are other some of those
other things you're like yeah i
definitely needed that experience
because it taught me this this and this
of course mostly in general i mean i
needed him
too he was a lifesaver god put him in my
life for a reason yeah at the
perfect time and just everything that he
taught me
um with like i said responding the right
way with
with him not lashing out um with just
praying and
and just seeing that like i'm okay and
that
if i do things the right way that i'll
be fine so it mostly
like i needed him and
forever he saved my life don't put on
the show
you win the game don't put on the show
you freaking win the game
you don't put on the show you win you
get in the paint
and you finish and you win and you
defend you rebound
and you play together come on let's go
let's go
experience in general i think a lot of
people don't even know that with a lot
of players
there's so many sacrifices that people
end up there everybody's not just there
because of grades
sometimes it's just sacrifice um i think
even for you like is that something you
also realize when you were there like
just
hearing other stories of the players and
how they got there it's like oh
like they all have similar stories or at
least have all been through something
while we're here you know i mean
know uh really i mean in that moment
coach mosley he was getting on us
about how we weren't giving it out and
complaining about
not doing the extra and for him
it was like you're gonna come every day
you're going to give it to all
because ultimately you don't want to be
here you don't want to be in this place
i don't want you you need to be at the
next level we want to get you to the
next level so you're going to do
everything you're supposed to to get to
the next level
and at that point he had enough of us
complaining and he felt as if
we weren't giving it all and all of that
so he was saying that i'm
sacrificing here i'm missing my daughter
softball
my game and my son's practices all of
that stuff and
you're complaining to me and i felt i
mean we
we understood we felt what he was
talking about and
in that moment we we decided to
reconvene and come as a group
as the guys and get it together and do
the lift and
get out of there but he was just trying
to make a point that
i mean you don't want to be in this
place the juco grind is real
so you you have to work just just that
much harder just to get out you know
what i'm saying
yeah that's tough kid like joe he knows
how to play
so i i have to give him a chance until
he is a detriment to everybody else in
the program it was also like i'm not
going to give up on you either so
whatever it takes for me to get you back
i'm gonna go do it which is a shout out
to him yeah for that that's not stuff
you have you have another one i know you
said there was another one too
yeah yeah i mean this is another good
story uh
like an inspirational story like as far
as coaching
when i first came to eli i
transferred to pasadena city college and
my grades weren't good
i was originally supposed to go to long
beach state from pasadena philly college
in 2017.
my grades weren't good enough i was
slacking this is one of the times i was
knucklehead open cases and stuff
on the run all of that and
when i got the call and someone told me
like yo well coach mosley
he'll help you out you go out there just
do what you got to do
meeting went great i got enrolled to
school and
got into classes told me about the guys
i met the guys
then i started to work out in practice
i'm expecting to play
right i'm expecting to i'm practicing
i'm
practicing uniform going to school going
to class
now i was to be honest i'm slacking here
and there not showing up
doing my usual slacking here and there
but i'm i'm in school i'm going to class
or whatever
yeah he hits me with the you're not
playing the season
you're here to get your grades up and do
what you're supposed to off the court
don't worry about the court next year so
my first time touching the court was
this past season
with last chance you of what you've seen
oh
i got you okay okay that was that wasn't
initially what you thought it was gonna
be like you thought i was gonna play
guys i'm thinking i was gonna play at
least two years to get
you know said and balanced again yeah
yeah you know but
he he he did the extra yeah to make sure
that i
would be good now for me yeah
listen listen and you are what steps did
you have to take
i think a lot of people don't understand
that in between part where it's like
i have to now adjust you know i i did
penn state then i did another college
and now i'm here
what is it like trying to gather
yourself and be like this is now the
route that i have to go and i have to
accept what it is and what's
what it's going to be like so i can get
to where i'm trying
it's like it's a lot um it's a lot it's
a total mentally really
um because you really you have times
where you you feel like
is this really what i want to do because
i mean like you said
i was at university at oak hill and i'm
playing this high quality d1 basketball
with all these good players
and then i'll take a step back and
they're playing juco basketball not
necessarily bad players
still good players but it's not the same
level of basketball it's not the same
play that i'm used to playing with and
it was days where like i felt like
i wasn't getting any better or going
anywhere with it and it was
taking a toll on you mentally and i had
to realize sit down and think
like if this is really what i want to do
i want this is my i loved and
i'm gonna fight diversity hat on and i'm
gonna i'm gonna push through it because
it's white at the end of the tour
you're always gonna win it dude but
you know what i'm saying that's how it
goes best team
appreciate each and every one of y'all
you know how we saw how once kovitt
uh canceled the tournament for united
state um
i think everybody can agree that that
was one of the toughest finales of any
show that we've watched from a viewer's
standpoint but being in it
like what was that like like just
knowing that you guys have put in so
much work and then
you know it was done just like that what
what do you remember from that moment
the most
uh i just remember how bad we wanted to
win
we worked for plan in the champions
state championship game
that's what our goal was and everything
that we did leading up to it was for
that purpose
and to get all the way up to that point
and no one did anything to affect it
it's just like a natural thing like it's
just something that we can't control
it was it was hard and and to take that
um
it was tough we had the emotions flowing
crazy coach cried
we we some of the players cry i cried
what we wanted the state championship
yeah by the way no no and the show was
like right after that like you
you have an abrupt ending and then i
forgot who mentioned it but it's also
like
that affects a lot of everybody's like
recruiting or you know maybe college
looks that maybe would have helped other
people so it's done like that
and then now we're just sitting around
chilling for the next whatever amount of
months not knowing
where you're going to head to next do
you remember those those in between
months between
you know after it ended and before what
was
what was it like just chilling waiting
do
i know i wasn't chilling i was panicking
bro
i was panicking like i because for me i
wanted to be
a division one basketball player i
wanted to give back to
the to that stage to where i belong and
i didn't want to set myself short
i wasn't going division two i wasn't
going d3 and no disrespect to those
programs and those leagues or whatever
i just couldn't do it there like that's
just not where i wanted to be that's not
where i saw myself excelling
and it was tough like i mean
i was panicking like if i was sitting
around
working out staying ready just waiting
on the car staying in touch with coach
mosley man
most people call me like you know i told
the long beach
they just said this and this and this
and i'm getting hyped and
waiting waiting waiting just sitting and
then randomly out of nowhere
um long beach calling and told me like
yo come on we want you
like wow yes you moved in like let's go
and i'm like oh we're going the long
piece
i need to know what was in those churros
man
what what was in those churros bro i
need some doughs and the churros
do you understand how much i love
excuse my language man but i have to say
it was cracking them jumps man
i'm saying
[Music]
what he did like the guy who made him
like he owned this material business or
whatever and
it was bomb but he had this like
caramel strawberry drizzle
yeah it's built it was crazy it's a lot
and it it's like if you got a sweet soup
it's perfect for you
but it was really good that's right yeah
i saw it i was like yo these dudes and
the fact you were like yo i think you
were like yeah i could even i could
definitely do some more of these like
this
ain't just the first i know i went like
three times in a row
i respect it